en el vídeo anterior les presenté una de
las funciones más extrañas que hemos
visto hasta el momento y esta es la
función de irak función delta de irak
y la definimos como y bueno voy a
dibujar la versión desplazada espero que
le sea familiar ahorita que la escriba
la función delta de irak de temenos se
puede decir que es igual a 0 cuando te
es diferente de c pero esencialmente va
a subir hasta infinito y hay que tener
cuidado con este infinito lo voy a
escribir aquí pero no se entiende como
un valor infinito tal cual porque
podemos multiplicar esto por números más
grandes para tener una función del tav
idac todavía más grande cuando te es
igual a c
pero más importante que esto digamos que
esta es una pseudo definición lo que
estoy señalando acá lo más importante es
la idea de que cuando tomamos la
integral el área bajo la curva de menos
infinito a infinito la integral cuando
tomamos de la de abajo esta curva que va
a ser igual a cero excepto en el valor
de c cuando tomamos esta área va a ser
igual a 1 y esta es la parte importante
que el área va a ser igual a 1 el área
siempre va a ser igual a 1 y es a esto
lo que me refiero en cuanto a un pseudo
infinito si tuviera el doble de la
función delta de irak
si yo estuviera tomando el área bajo la
curva de eso el doble de la función
delta vida
dt será igual a 2 por la integral de
menos infinito infinito de mi función en
el cadillac desplazada la función del
calidad de t menos por de t
que sería igual a 2 x nuestra definición
esto es igual a 1 2 x 1 igual a 2
así que si yo pongo un 2 aquí ese
infinito tendría que ser el doble de
alto para que el área ahora sea 2 y es
por eso que puse este infinito entre
comillas pero es una función bastante
interesante y les comentaba al final del
vídeo anterior que esto nos ayuda a
modelar cosas que se sacuden de pronto
sobre cosas que imparten una cierta
cantidad de impulso a algo una cantidad
fija de cambio en el momento y esto lo
vamos a comprender un poquito mejor en
el futuro pero primero vamos a
comprender estas herramientas
matemáticas ahora veamos qué pasa con la
transformada de la clase de esta función
de alta de dídac cuando lo multiplicamos
por una función digamos que yo tengo mi
función delta de irak que está
desplazada de menos c y si ustedes no
quieren la versión desplazada pues
simplemente hacer lo igualan a 0 y voy a
tomar la versión desplazada y la voy a
multiplicar
una función arbitraria en ti y ahora
quiero encontrar la transformada de la
plaza de la función delta cuando ft es
igual a 1 y ahora vamos a tomar la
transformada de la plaza de todo esto
y vamos a usar la definición de la
transformada de la plaza que es la
integral de 0 a infinito de
a la menos ese porte que viene de la
definición de nuestra transformada de la
plaza
x lo que tenemos aquí dentro ft por
nuestra función delta de irak
dt m
y aquí agregamos dt
aquí quiero hacer un argumento un poco
más intuitivo pues ya que muchas de las
matemáticas que hemos hecho y en
especial uno tiende a ser muy riguroso y
formal en cuanto se refiere a la función
delta de irak pero lógica que podemos
trabajar con esto de manera intuitiva
voy a resolver esta integral para
ustedes de manera intuitiva y creo que
ustedes lo encontrarán en el sentido así
que ahora permítanme dibujar este par de
ejes para mostrarles lo que queremos
hacer para mostrarles a lo que le quiero
tomar la integral sólo me interesa la
porción de 0 a infinito por eso estoy
dibujando nada más esta parte de los
ejes y también cuando se es mayor que 0
ya que la función delta va a mostrarse
de manera positiva en el lado derecho de
mi gente y como se va a ver esta primera
parte esta parte de ea la menos 7 por ft
bueno no lo sé con él a menos s te va a
comenzar en 1 y va a bajar x una función
arbitraria así que la voy a dibujar más
o menos así imaginando que así se ve en
nuestra función
al menos 7 por ft
y la parte de frente es la que le da
esta forma extraña muy bien ahora vamos
a graficar nuestra función delta de irak
donde vamos a tener cero en todos los
valores excepto en ce y justo en c justo
aquí va a subir de manera infinita pero
recuerden que solo dibujamos una flecha
hasta el valor 1 indicando el tamaño del
área bajo esta curva recordemos que el
área es 1 de nuestra función delta dídac
y bueno cuando se grafica no se dibujan
flechas pero van en este caso esta
flecha indica que es el área bajo la
curva que es igual a 1 y ahora vamos a
multiplicar esto la definición de la
función delta desplazada hace
cuando multiplico esto por esto que es
lo que obtengo esta es la intuición
básica aquí permíteme dibujar los ejes a
ver si los me salen un poquito más
derechas
más o menos así
ok no me juzguen por lo derecho de mis
ejes
este este y que pase cuando multiplico
estos dos cuando te es igual a cualquier
otra cosa excepto ce la función de
altamed irak va a ser cero cierto cuando
te es diferente de ce no me va a
interesar el valor de todo lo que esté
alrededor toda esta función va a ser
igual a cero así que va a ser cero en
todos los valores excepto en ce y aquí
va a pasar algo interesante cuando te es
igual hace aquí cuál es el valor de la
función bueno va a ser el valor de la
función delta dirac multiplicado por la
altura que tenga y esa altura va a ser
este punto de aquí que estoy señalando
ese punto
y ese va a ser el valor de esta función
evaluar en sí
y lo voy a marcar en amarillo aquí en el
eje de la siesta o en el eje de la cfc
como ustedes lo quieran llamar esto es a
la - s por c multiplicada por f de c
todo lo que estoy haciendo es evaluar
esta función en ce y es este punto de
aquí si toman ustedes este punto que es
sólo un número puede ser un 55 por esto
y ustedes obtienen 5 x la función delta
de irak o en este caso bueno no es un 5
es un número más abstracto pero lo
pueden dibujar así cuando ustedes
multiplican esto por mi pequeña función
delta obtengo esto la altura va a ser
una función de alta pero escalada al
valor de mi función así que mi nuevo
valor va a quedar así
si yo multiplico esto por esto me va a
quedar en esencia
al menos ese por c x fdc y que bueno
puede lucir como una función
extravagante pero realmente es un número
al menos desde el punto de vista de t
sabemos que ese está en el dominio de la
transformada de la plasta pero desde el
punto de vista de t estas son puros
constantes esta constante multiplicada
por mi función delta de irak
multiplicada por delta de t - c cuando
multiplico esto por esto todo lo que me
queda es esto y esa altura aún va a ser
infinitamente alta pero va a estar
escalada de tal manera que su área que
su área no va a ser 1
y se los voy a mostrar y cuál va a ser
la integral de esto si yo hago la
integral de menos infinito hasta más
infinito pues debería ser lo mismo que
tomar la integral de los infinito
infinito así que vamos a hacerlo aunque
de hecho de vamos a hacer la integral de
cero a infinito así que si hacemos la
integral de cero a infinito
lo que estoy diciendo es que tomar está
integral es equivalente a tomar esta
otra integral así que a la menos s por c
efe
de c x la función delta vida de t - c dt
ahora esta cosa de aquí yo estoy
afirmando que esto es equivalente a esto
ya que en cualquier otra parte la
función delta de irak me va a hacer 0
esta función por lo que sólo nos
interesa esta función cuando se tiene el
valor de c y esto se vuelve una
constante si esto es una constante
entonces podemos quitarla de esta
integral
lo voy a poner de este lado nada más
pues para ahorrar un poco de espacio
quitamos la constante de esta integral
y obtenemos el ala menos s porsche por
efe de c
x la integral de 0 infinito de f
dt m dt
el perdón es efe de tms
perdón
esto es o no es una f esta es la delta
la función delta dídac
entonces bueno recapitulamos sacamos las
constantes y esta va a ser la integral
de ser infinito de delta de t - c dt y
bueno
ahora por definición que es esto
todo esto es uno
aunque sea la integral de cero a
infinito no importa por la función en
esta parte es igual a 1 ya que el único
momento en el que tiene un valor o que
tiene una área es cuando esto es igual a
c así que todo esto es igual a 1 y por
lo tanto toda esta integral de acá se
reduce a esto
al menos ese porsche multiplicada por
fcc
y la voy a escribir aquí de nuevo aquí
abajo la transformada de la plaza de
nuestra función del tab irak desplazada
espacios a la derecha multiplicada por
efe dt es igual esencialmente estamos
evaluando esta función cuando te es
igual a c así que por eso aquí tenemos
cuando es la menos c por s x la función
en sí lo que estamos haciendo es evaluar
todo esto en c y a partir de esto
podemos obtener varias cosas
interesantes por ejemplo cuál es la
transformada de la plaza de nuestra
función delta dídac así insólita bueno
en este caso tenemos que se es igual a 0
y f
dt o
va a ser igual a 1
es un término constante si hacemos esto
entonces la transformada de laplace de
esto va a ser igual a e a la menos cero
por s por 1 que va a ser igual a 1 así
que la transformada de la plaza de
nuestra función delta de irak es uno que
esto es algo bastante bueno de descubrir
y si hiciéramos la transformada de la
plaza de nuestra función desplazada
transformada de la plaza de nuestra
función delta de t
ese es un caso especial en el que ft es
igual a 1 aquí podría escribir x 1 pero
bueno es obvio eso sin iguala a la - c
por s x fdc pero aquí esto es 1 x 1 que
da igual
así que esa es mi transformada de la
plaza a la menos cs y así usando una
herramienta de evaluación visual hemos
podido encontrar las transformadas de la
plaza de varias situaciones que
involucran nuestra función delta de irak
espero que encuentren esto útil nos
vemos en el siguiente vídeo